they're the most severe sanctions ever
imposed on a single country russia says
they amount to a declaration of war as
the west expands its measures will
vladimir putin be forced to stop his war
on ukraine and have sanctions worked in
the past this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
hazm seeker it's been more than two
weeks since russia launched its invasion
of ukraine eu leaders have been meeting
in france to talk about more ways to
help ukraine and further punish russia
but that hasn't stopped the kremlin from
hitting back moscow has now imposed an
exports ban on a string of products
until the end of this year about 48
countries will be affected including the
us and those in the eu russia is already
facing the most severe set of western
sanctions ever imposed on a single
country they target a variety of sectors
including oil banking aviation and
people close to president putin this is
a defining moment for europe
and
it is a moment where we see that putin's
war
is also a question
of the resilience of democracies we will
rethink energy
we have to get rid of the dependency of
russian fossil fuels and for that we
need
massive investment in renewables this is
also a strategic investment in our
security and our independence
our russian president vladimir putin
says his country will emerge stronger
and more independent from western
sanctions which he said were inevitable
the pressure of sanctions has always
existed of course today it is of a more
complicated nature and is posing certain
questions problems and difficulties on
us
but we will overcome them now just like
we have overcome problems in previous
years at the end of the day all of this
will lead to the increase of our
independence autonomy and sovereignty
let's take a closer look at the growing
number of international companies that
have pulled out of russia mcdonald's
coca-cola and starbucks are among the
latest corporations suspending
operations after russia's invasion of
ukraine germany's volkswagen and japan's
toyota both halted production in russia
indefinitely
and several tech firms have closed up
shop including software companies
microsoft and
sap fashion brands h m and zara have
also joined the corporate exodus
well let's bring in our guests now
joining us from london chris wiefer
chief executive officer at macro
advisory a strategic consultancy focused
on russia and eurasia in oslo glenn
diesen professor of international
relations at the university of south
eastern norway and also in london tom
burgess author of the sunday times
best-selling book kleptopia how dirty
money is conquering the world
good to have you all uh with us
gentlemen uh chris wiefer let me start
with you what are these sanctions as
they currently stand
working
um they're starting to have an impact
for sure but let me just say up front
though that the sanctions although very
severe are not likely to lead to a
financial collapse
or even an economic collapse uh as maybe
we've seen uh previously and and that's
because russia has been living under a
sanctions regime which has been
tightening ever since 2014 so the
economy to some extent has built in
if you like some resilience
to sanctions uh but but not of course to
the extent we're now seeing so we are
starting to see some companies laying
off staff because they cannot get spare
parts because of the trade embargo we're
starting to see of course high-profile
brands like ikea mcdonald's and others
uh at least temporarily closing their
business in russia which is leading to
layoffs and then a shortage of goods so
we're starting to see this creeping
impact on on the economy but as i say in
terms of financial stability or kind of
overall macroeconomic stability that's
not yet at risk and won't be so long as
russia could is able to continue
exporting key products such as gas or
industrial materials and is able to be
paid for it so
you know in that sense no collapse but
clearly a deteriorating situation chris
uh tom burgess what's your take on on
how
uh
effective these sanctions are what the
overall effect of them is well i think
we have to break them into their two
parts there's the sectoral sanctions as
they're known which is essentially the
sort of economic attack
uh
reducing uh purchases of russian exports
like oil and gas trade embargoes the
kind of things chris was talking about a
moment ago um and then there's the
targeted sanctions um
which are sort of
subtler and harder to read in a way
these are obviously the attacks on the
personal wealth
of those who have prospered under
putin's kleptocracy for many years um
they are being touted as a way to put
pressure on him i i would offer a note
of skepticism with those as well i would
say the two categories of oligarchs the
1990s oligarchs who um
got rich in the privatizations and then
had their wings clipped rather by putin
and were made dependent on him but but
but maintain relationships with him
they i think have limited influence on
his decision-making and then there's the
kind of putin era oligarchs who um a lot
of whom have
like him past in the kgb
um and or in some cases kind of plot
from obscurity and created by putin they
have a much greater personal dependency
on him
and they're also sort of barrens of
state companies generally oil gas
pipelines etc as opposed to private ones
um but if the aim of the sanctions is to
ultimately to persuade
the um
the the richest beneficiaries of
russia's kleptocracy that they need a
new boss at the top because putin's
policies are proving to ruin us for
their wealth you've got to question that
logic as well because so many of them
are so bound up with him that
typically in my experience of covering
kleptocracies all over the world when
when the big man goes down those close
to him go down with him so you've got to
wonder to what extent
that they would see it as in their
interest to try to remove putin at any
stage
yeah i mean we can certainly talk more
about that a little bit later this is
this is related to britain's decision
isn't it to put several russian
oligarchs on their sanctions list
because many of them have have a lot of
their money um in in uk uh banks um so
yeah we will talk a little bit more that
in in a moment but i want to turn to
glenn diesel and get his take on on the
sanctions overall the history of
sanctions as far as having the desired
effect of of getting
the people that they are targeting to to
change their position or
get them to back down is is not a great
one is it it's it's checkered at best
do you expect this to be any different
no i i well this is the problem often
with sanctions they're put in place
because well politicians feel they have
to do something and it's either
economics
pressure or military pressure
but sometimes you know doing something
doesn't necessarily mean it's anything's
achieved now
when we ask whether or not the sanctions
will be are working if they're
successful it really depends what
what we consider the purpose of the
sanctions to be if it is to weaken the
russian economy as a strategic adversary
then i would say yes the sanctions are
working if it is to decouple
[Music]
russia from the european economist then
yes it's also working however one would
also have to point out that since 2014
russia is working towards reorienting
its economy from the west towards the
east mainly china and this will only
intensify the process but but typically
when we talk about sanctions the purpose
is to
make the adversary change their policy
we're so we're influencing the
cost-benefit
analysis of russian actions but in order
to assess the extent which sanctions
will be effective really have to say
well
what are russia's motivation and i think
often we get it there wrong
well one gets the impression from the
media that putin just woke up one day in
a bad mood decided to you know conquer
some new territory i think it's
important to see the russian perspective
on this and this is that
after nato expansionism for the past 30
years russia said this is a threat to
their security for the past 15 years
they made it very clear that
ukraine's absorption into nato is an
existential threat so in other words
this is a red line and
we and that they will effectively risk
everything for this so it's all or
nothing it's a little bit like a united
states we're willing to obliterate cuba
in order to get the soviets out so i
think it's under important understand
this because
if russia sees this effectively as a
defensive war if you want or getting
nato away from its borders then they
can't retreat what would happen if
russia would go back pull his forces out
today with the mood we have in the west
nato would work moves directly in with
weapons and everything else into ukraine
fairly quickly and again this is
something that russia cannot do so i
think the russians are willing to absorb
an enormous amount of economic pain and
they're not going to back down because
again for them this is an existential
threat it's a red line so i don't see
any future for the sanctions uh i think
if we don't want to change you would
have to talk about some security
arrangements with russia
okay chris wiefer
putin has said that
russia's strong enough to withstand
sanctions and that this will end up
hurting the west in the form of higher
food and energy prices is he right
well we can already see that include the
price of commodities key commodities
energy but also other commodities that
russia is an important supplier of for
example wheat uh another soft
agriculture
products all of these prices are rising
so it is putting inflationary pressure
on the global economy and therefore that
will affect uh monetary policy uh
policies and will will affect the global
economy so he's right in that respect
but to what extent russia can withstand
the pain and how long it can withstand
clearly is is an open question russia as
as i said earlier has made a lot of
preparations
uh you know to be more resilient against
sanctions for example if we go back to
2013
uh russia was entirely dependent on oil
price needed 115 dollars a year to
balance its budget this year it'd be
less than 50 although it's been equal
back then russia imported 50 of its food
consumption mostly from europe or from
the west now russia is completely
self-sufficient so there's no risk of
any food shortages certainly basic items
on the shelves uh and at the start of
this year russia had built up
substantial financial war chest
630 billion
dollars the fifth highest in the world
and we also know that the central bank
has greatly dispersed those reserves so
even though the central bank is now
sanctioned and and reserves held in
western banks are sanctioning countries
that they can't access but a lot of
reserves have been moved to china and
moved elsewhere where they can access
them so in that sense putin is right in
saying that russia can withstand a lot
of pain because uh he he has
made the economy a lot more resilient to
banking system etc is a lot stronger
than it used to be but the critical
factor though to repeat is uh so long as
russia is able to export its key
commodities such as gas and other
materials and be paid for them so long
as there are some banks remaining in the
swift system then russia is earning by
our estimate at least 30 billion dollars
current account surplus every month
because imports have collapsed so the
current account surplus has gone up and
that's a substantial financial lifeline
which means that the government can
continue to fund employment subsidies
maintain domestic economic stability
fund social programs
etc pensions etc and then that means
this situation in russia not ideal it's
not growing mcdonald's have closed but
there really is no danger of an economic
or financial collapse and that probably
means that social pressures won't be
that much either
uh tom burgess going back to
the issue around uh the oligarchs and
going after the the russian oligarchs
particularly those as you said who are
who are very close to putin
the later generation
and
the thinking here as as you were saying
is that these sanctions will somehow
it's hoped to put the squeeze on them
because they've they've hitched their
wagon to putin up to now and um
they might think about turning against
him but could they even weather this
uh financially because this is coming
more than two weeks into this war now
there's been criticism of the british
government that they've acted too slow
would they have had time then to to kind
of move their money elsewhere so that no
one no one can touch it i mean is it is
it
too little too late at this point
yeah i mean i just first of all just
have to quickly take issue with the idea
that um
defensive what
this is kind of i have to take issue
with the idea of this is a defensive war
i mean the let's let's let's be clear
about what what the russian regime is
it's a regime of thieves you know putin
as soon as he came back to saint
petersburg um
at the end of the cold war began
enriching himself um through corruption
and he's just massively gone on
magnifying that process and applebar
brilliantly described him as he's just
they're the first among a group of
billionaires the one who controls the
secret police
that's the engine of putin's regime is
corruption it's it's a kleptocracy it
runs on corruption now that means that
it requires um
extraordinary feats of propaganda to to
maintain control part of the propaganda
has been um these scare stories about
the nazification and the militarization
of ukraine and this is what's been used
as a false pretext for the invasion now
the it's it it follows from that that
the motivations of putin of those around
him are in many senses material are
about their own access to wealth and the
security that that brings so targeting
that wealth
is important as you say though the way
the west has gone about it in the uk but
also europe and the us has been
pretty sloppy especially in the uk the
enormous delay in imposing sanctions
when they were obviously coming leads to
a lot of anecdotal accounts of yeah
money being
spirited away before names right to the
sanctions list further to that the uk's
record of enforcing sanctions is
absolutely pitiful it remains the case
that the uk like the rest of the world
continues to allow this insane idea of
financial secrecy which has become so
widespread we've become accustomed to it
but you can if you're rich enough
participate in a democratic
free market economy in disguise behind a
front company so you put a few names on
the list and you maybe cause trouble for
chelsea and you grab a few yachts but we
don't know what the russian kleptocracy
is really doing with it with its wealth
because we allow them to move it around
in secret the the final point i'd make
and it picks up on
something that was raised earlier is
that is the prospect that this could
backfire by accelerating what i called
in my book the rise of kleptopia right
and alliances of kleptocrats by pushing
the russian kleptocratic elite but also
the
economy more generally
into um alliances with other um
ultra-corrupt states china venezuela
iran they all wear different kind of
ideological masks but essentially
they're all the political systems are
all
engines for the enrichments of the
powerful and the more we use sanctions
donald trump used them incredibly
liberally the more we use them the
bigger the club of outcasts get and the
more that club of outcasts band together
and if you throw everyone out then
sanctions ultimately become pointless
because there's an alternative economy
that people can operate in let's talk a
little bit more about the the potential
economic blowback on this
a little bit more widely glenn diesen is
there a real danger that these sanctions
will end up hurting too many people uh
too many ordinary people in in the west
in the form of inflation higher energy
prices which we're already seeing now
well yeah energy uh
food production i think a lot of this or
in all these areas you're going to see a
much higher prices but then energy is
very interesting area because once
energy prices goes up everything else
has to go up
so i i think it's going to be very hard
to control this it has to be pointed out
that this is why the europeans have been
very cautious
to follow the american lead on this to
have this
to these very strict sanctions which
effectively reversal bridges with with
russia and i think there's also other
problems uh uh that that are coming down
the road because uh
um well as the previous speaker
mentioned that one of the problems with
sanctions is obviously if they're too
harsh and endures for too long
the one you're punishing simply learns
to live without you they they they find
alternatives and
i think there's too many countries now
being being sanctioned from
china russia iran i think a lot of these
countries have an incentive now to
establish a parallel economic
infrastructure which they already are
they are they are seeking to cut off
from the western technologies western
industries want to use their
transportation corridors their banks
their us dollar swift i mean also there
have been created alternatives for all
of this and of course they still have a
lot of work to be done but uh
but this is obviously the trend so you
can only use the sanctions for so long
uh but beyond how the sanctions directly
on russia will affect the west you also
have to keep in mind that china and
other countries are also watching as
well because this is becoming a case
study in what might happen to them in
the future so
if you're sitting in beijing now would
you want to be ex would you want to be
vulnerable by having dependence on the
dollar on you know using swift uh
holding u.s debt in any real estate
using american technologies its banks
certainly you are now making preparation
to cut off from america to reduce and
your
lesser extent to reduce your
vulnerability
so this is the situation we're in with
this excessive sanctions any economic
dependence become effectively weaponized
by the adversaries so uh so so with with
the harshness of these sanctions i don't
think
it has been properly thought how this
could play out also just on the final
point how is russia going to respond now
again
sanctioning the russian central bank is
this is very extreme stuff now we can
see russia might start to seize more
western assets it can nationalize
certain assets it can cut oil and gas
deliveries and instead focus on asia it
can
withdraw patents on businesses and
simply take over companies that are
leaving i'm not sure if it's possible
with mcdonald's for example simply to
save the workplaces and
just make one big final divorce from the
west and
just decide its future lies with the
east instead away from the nato
countries yeah let's put that to chris
wiefer i mean
glenn diesen brings up a point there
that russia has
weapons of its own economically and can
respond
uh in kind i mean how how damaging could
that be
for the countries that are that are that
are targeting russia
yeah yeah
of course this is uh if this were to
happen it would be enormously damaging
for the global economy because you just
have to look at a map and and see that
russia is the major kind of commodity
supplier for for the world not just oil
and gas but uh wheat uh ukraine and
russia were the two biggest producers of
wheat and ukraine exports are now of
course disruptive
um but also coal uh nickel palladium and
all sorts of uh materials so if russia
if those exports from russia were to
stop then clearly the global economic
impact would be very severe and we'd
have a global recession but it's
important to bear in mind that you know
at least as it stands right now uh
president putin and other people around
him continue to say that russia will
continue to honor all export contracts
now of course what they're saying is
that particularly to europe if europe
continues to buy
russian gas as per the contract and the
volumes and the pricing then russia will
continue to supply and for example every
gas perm every day excuse me sends an
update that it is uh you know sending
gas through all the various routes
including across ukraine every day as
per the contract and this was the same
in the soviet union there was never a
supply uh disruption so i think that you
know essentially what russia is saying
that provided uk paying us and the
routes for which we can be paid such as
some banks in the swift system then we
will keep supplying but they clearly
never lose an opportunity to remind the
rest of the world just how dependent the
global economy is on russian commodities
i'm talking about the question of
nationalization that is important also
because um when you talk about companies
like coca-cola or or other brands um
they're essentially russian companies
they employ russian people
and they source their product mostly in
russia now ikea and a few others are
different that's why ikea had to close
quite quickly because it could not
import uh flat pack furniture etc but in
the case of mcdonald's and other
companies that are sourcing their
materials inside the country are
essentially russian companies in terms
of employment and paying taxes then what
the russian government is saying is that
they want those companies to stay they
prefer them to stay and actually they're
offering incentives for companies to
stay even recognizing that some
companies are under
global consumer or stakeholder pressure
to temporarily
close they're accepting that they're
acknowledging that but they still want
to them to stay but if they choose to go
if companies say we are now exiting
russia uh we are not coming back then
the russian government has said that
their businesses could be nationalized
because they want to protect russian
jobs or the assets could be confiscated
and sold elsewhere and then just very
quickly aligned with that we have seen
china already saying that their big
companies are now actively looking at
asset acquisition opportunities
particularly in strategic sectors such
as energy bar or materials they will be
a keen buyer for any western assets to
become available and russia will
accommodate that all right just turning
back then to to tom burgess on what's
probably going to be the last word on
this coming back to the to the oligarchs
is there a kind of
if you look at the optics of this is
there a sort of messaging problem that
the west has uh with with ukrainians in
that you know what's what's going after
a few russian billionaires going to do
for
the millions of ukrainians who are
suffering uh right now that you know
they've got enough money
uh to weather this so
what kind of i mean do you think do you
think there's there's a
a messaging issue there in terms of
showing uh ukraine that that the west is
fully behind them
yeah and actually i think it goes much
further than that i think um
you know you
read the the the statement that
the uk and other western governments
have made to accompany their sanctions
decisions to justify why
eagle section or oleg dara pasca or um
roman abramovich or whoever is going on
this list and
there's very little information as far
as i can see in any of those that we
didn't know a week ago a month ago a
year ago that we didn't know in some
cases back when um putin murdered
litvinenko on the streets of london or
more pointedly we didn't know when putin
annexed crimea in 2014 but up until now
our decision has essentially been you
know what we'd rather keep the money
and um
i think there is a mismatch in what
we're doing now and
what could um what the ukrainians might
feel they could demand of us
unfortunately that's going to have to be
the last word we're out of time thank
you to all three of you chris wiefer
clen diesen and tom burgess thanks very
much for being on inside story and thank
you as always for watching remember you
can see this program again anytime just
go to our website at jazeera.com and for
further discussion go to our facebook
page that's facebook doc com forward
slash aj inside story you can also join
the conversation on twitter our handle
there is at aj inside story for me has
them seeker and the entire team here bye
for now
[Music]
you